i had this skill with mathematical tools
and
i played these tools as well as i could
just because it was beautiful
just as a rather in the same way a
musician plays a violin not
not expecting to change the world but
just because
he loves the instrument
my name is freeman dyson and i'm a
professor retired at the institute for
advanced study in princeton
and when i was a young kid i used to
scribble big numbers and
draw pictures of the solar system so
obviously i was interested right from
the start
i think the decisive moment in my
career path was reading the book men of
mathematics by eric temple bell he
showed the mathematicians as being
mostly crooks and and the people are
very
mixed kind of qualities
not at all saints
many of them quite unscrupulous and not
very clever
and still they managed to do great
mathematics so it told the kid that
if they can do it why can't you and
that was certainly what turned me on i
came from england to the united states
to study physics
i applied to cornell university
to work with hans peter who is a famous
physicist
but the amazing thing was in the very
first week i was there i met dick
feynman
who is an absolute genius and of course
i'd never even heard of him he was not
so famous in those days but i
immediately realized this was the guy
and and he was such a tremendous
just sparkling character
a clown and always telling stories and
in addition to that very brilliant and
and so
so i attached myself to feynman as
quickly as i could
he was working on these problems of
quantum electrodynamics
and he had done a great deal which was
very beautiful but which nobody else
understood
and he loved to talk and i loved to
listen
so within six months i pretty well
mastered his language
and within one year i actually was able
to improve on it and i translated his
ideas into mathematics and so it became
more accessible to the world
and as a result
i became famous and
but it all happened within about six
months
i was very much interested in space
travel and and
so the next exciting thing i did
actually
was to work with a company in california
called general atomic which still exists
i worked for the company for a couple of
years building a spaceship and so we
decided we would go around the solar
system with a spaceship driven by
nuclear bombs so
we would launch the ship into space
going up about four bombs per second
going up
and
all the way to mars and then afterwards
to jupiter and saturn and we intended to
go ourselves
we had actual model spaceships
about so big about about a meter in
diameter or so
with chemical explosives which actually
went bom bom bom bom a few times
a few hundred feet up so that lasted for
two years
by that time it was clear that the
competition was actually going to win
the competition being vienna from brown
and the apollo program which was going
to go with ordinary rockets to the moon
i i think the notion that i'd like to
oppose the consensus in science is
totally wrong there's only one subject
that i've been controversial which is
climate
i'm not really a climate expert but i
have strong opinions
and
the most strong and firmly based of my
opinions is that this is really still a
mysterious subject and that climate is
not at all well understood i'm not
saying the majority is necessarily wrong
i'm saying that
they don't understand what
what they're seeing and and
so it will take a lot of very hard work
before that question is settled
people are often asking me what's going
to happen next in science that's
important and of course the whole point
is that if it's important it's something
we didn't expect but in order for
science to go on it has to have
mysteries that's what that's the way it
has been up till now
so i hope very much it continues
[Music]
you